welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Doctor Strange and the
Multiverse of Madness revealed new VFX
details from the Multiverse Montage
sequence confirming one of our theories
about the 27 universes Doctor Strange
America Chavez tumbled through but not
in the way we expected because folks I
hate to break it to you but Hydra wins
in one of the universes of the FC
Multiverse confirmed by the bfx artists
who worked on this film so I'm gonna
break down the full implications of this
alternate universe but how it sets up
Red's goal to return in secret Wars in
Multiverse event it's Doctor Strange
America Chavez escaped the Scarlet Witch
and camartaj by falling through the
Multiverse I counted over 20 different
universes shown throughout this film but
among these I theorized that one of them
showed us the version of Manhattan had
Hydra successfully invaded the United
States for example had red skull's
valkyrie's ship in the first Captain
America film The One loaded with
Warheads signed sealed and delivered for
Steve Rogers Hometown had actually made
it to their intended target and now in
an interview with variety bfx artist
Alexis wise bro sorry if I said that
wrong from frame store and artist Olivia
Dumont and Michael Perdue from Luma
pictures finally confirmed some of the
multiversal details that we had been
wondering about things like the squid
monster Dr Strange fights was supposed
to be shumagorath but due to rights
issues they had to name it gargantos but
still was considered a variant of
shumagorath in their eyes but the France
or artists shared one still of the black
and white film stock into are showing in
1930s New York with a blimp looming over
the Brooklyn Bridge if you look closely
at the nose of that blimp that is a
Sigil of Hydra this is confirmed to be a
universe where Hydra took over the
United States and unlike the way the
organization covertly corrupted shield
from the inside in the shadows using
artem Zola's algorithm this version of
Hydra proudly brandishes their
iconography for all to see now the film
stock imagery in the 1930s setting
definitely evokes the man in the High
Castle the Philip K dick story turned
Amazon Prime series which told the story
of an alternate history where America
was defeated by the Axis powers in World
War II and featured some pretty chilling
imagery at the Nazi flag draped over New
York landmarks now I would say that's
what's happening in this reality except
you'll notice driving down the street
are some Classic Ford Model tease the
Tin Lizzies if this were truly after
World War II the automobiles especially
in Manhattan would probably be a mix of
a lot more newer models the Model T was
mass produced by Ford from 1908 to 1927
and that definitely stayed on the road
through the early 30s especially during
the Depression era but going into the
40s model T's became less and less
common they certainly wouldn't be every
car on the road as they are here so this
suggests that in this universe Hydra
invaded and conquered the United States
for World War II the timeline in which
Germany was able to mobilize into a
military State far sooner Annex same
European nations a lot sooner likely
Conquering the British Isles and making
their way across the Atlantic by the
mid-30s when model T's were still the
predominant car on the road but how
would they have been able to do that
what was the what if change in this
history well in the 616 MCU version of
World War II history the Germans formed
an alliance with the forces of Hydra led
by Johann Schmidt with Schmidt and arm
Zola working on a secret science
division for the Nazis producing
high-powered weaponry and powered by the
Tesseract the space Stone once those
weapons became operational Schmidt
turned on his Nazi overseers and took
Hydro Rogue but really Hydra as an
organization preceded World War II
because Agents of Shield Season 3 Trace
Hydra back to ancient times when a rogue
faction of Cree militants came to Earth
to create an army of super soldiers
human experiments that became
progenitors of the Inhumans led by Alias
AKA Hive who turned his inhuman group
into a cult until he was banished the
recruit monolith to a distant planet
over the Millennia the society grew and
evolved taking on new names trying to
save Hive from his Exile but to no avail
and the society became known as Hydra
actually needs to Shield flashbacks
showed Hydra in 1839 in England so the
group was obviously active in Europe a
century before World War II and before
you argue that Agents of Shield was not
MCU Cannon my friends Multiverse of
Madness just showed antimount Black Bolt
so these ABC Marvel TV shows are canon
in at least part of the MCU Multiverse
likely including the history of this
Hydra Universe therefore this Hydra
universe is likely one in which Johann
Schmidt's super soldier serum
experiments with Abraham Erskine before
Erskine broke away and fled U.S rather
than mutating Schmidt into Red Skull and
then abandoned when Erskine left with
his research in this case was seen as a
success and embraced and replicated
either a scenario where Erskine couldn't
make it to the U.S or one in which he
was captured instead of killed or his
serum made it back into the hands of
Schmidt and Zola and they built on that
research a what if scenario in which
Hydro rapidly expanded their super
soldier program on a mass scale decades
before they did this with the Winter
Soldier program where their Ambitions
were far less covert and turned all of
their soldiers that saluted red skull in
the first cap film into super soldiers
running them down assembly lines the way
Ford did their model T's imagine
thousands of german-speaking Steve
rogers's in blimps would make pretty
short work of a depression-era United
States now finding the deeper lay of
meanings and all these things can be so
stressful it makes you want to pull your
hair out but if you're worried about
losing your hair naturally keeps can
actually help you out there because two
out of three guys will experience some
form of male pattern baldness by the
time they're 35 with keeps you can get
quality expert care without ever
visiting a doctor's office or a pharmacy
keeps office generic versions of the
only two FDA approved hair loss products
out there but at half the cost of your
local pharmacy though you never have to
go to a doctor's office keeps has a
network of Expert Medical advisors
prescribers and Care Specialists to
support you in making your hair goals a
reality easily subscribe to keeps and
get refill reminders so you'll never run
low on the products you need to take
care of your hair hair loss stops with
keeps to get 50 off your first order go
to keeps.com Slash new rockstars or
click that link in the description
that's k-e-e-p-s.com new rockstars that
would mean red skull's vision of the
future a world United under flag the
flag of Hydra would actually be realized
and not to a rabbit hole into any
problematic thought experiments here but
really uh planet Earth that stops
warring amongst itself with Advanced
infinity stone powered Weaponry a power
source that doesn't spend decades in
storage or in Nick Fury's flurkin's
mouth the way the Tesseract did in the
main 616 timeline but rather one in the
hands of scientists more eager to build
on its power friends Hydra Earth is one
and at least better shape to defend
itself against Thanos or the cree or any
other extraterrestrial Invaders I know I
know I'm making an argument for Hydra
and other horrible things and at what
costs must the trains run on time I mean
if you use this argument we'd all be
better off assimilated into ego sticky
Galaxy orgy I don't know maybe so but it
doesn't mean we should yet still in this
Hydro universe as horrible yet efficient
as it is is likely one with Red Skull
still in charge no one to stop him which
would bring back a very interesting
villain to the MCU if the studio ever
wants to revisit this setting and I
think they're gonna do it for Secret
Wars because if Haley Atwell is a
live-action Captain Carter shows up in
Multiverse Madness obviously this movie
wanted to pay some homage to the variant
of the character in The what if series
and in that first episode we also saw
Red Skull back in a more active plot to
open a portal to unleash his Hydra Beast
something not too dissimilar to what
past generations of Hydra were doing in
Agents of Shield trying to free their
hive leader from a portal and Red Skull
voice actor Ross Marquan worked on
Multiverse of Madness as the voice of
the Ultron centuries in a3a the guy has
expressed interest in returning to the
MCU as red skull in the past so the
incursions there were off-referenced in
Multiverse Madness are most likely
pointing to an upcoming Secret Wars
event and rad skull is one villain we
definitely need to see returning
alongside the heroes and villains from
past phases now altogether on Battle
world and the Hydra universe is exactly
where he could pull a red skull from a
version of Johan Schmidt at the height
of his power his most villainous his ego
unchecked that is a Red Skull we deserve
let me know your thoughts on this Theory
you can follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at avos follow me Rockstar
subscribe to Rockstar some more analysis
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]